but um
what i want to do with with the
remaining 20 minutes or 25 minutes that
we've got uh
is
i have to give you a short introduction
to
two slides of my own philosophy
then i would like to invite discussion
um
both
further discussion about the structure
of the laplacian
world championships and i have
a big slide of questions here that we
can discuss
and then i also would like to invite
people in the room
who have been involved in various kinds
of implementation and experiments
to
give their points of view on things i
know that the there are
there is a non-zero number of people in
the room who have actually implemented
some of the combinatorial laplacian
solvers and i'd i'd like to i'd like to
hear from them i'd like to you know
depending on how many people raise their
hands give them give them give give a
few minutes to people um
the people listed on the slide here eric
and kevin
are
collaborators in an implementation
effort that we've done
which is not a fast implementation but a
sort of counting complexity
implementation which i will say a little
bit about at the end depending on how
the time goes i will either describe
extremely quickly in 30 seconds or in
detail depending on how the time goes
so but by way of introduction um
let me just
talk about graphs and sparse matrices
for one minute um
solving sparse linear systems has been a
foundation of scientific computation for
for for many many years um
for and
graph theory has contributed to sparse
matrix computation for 50 years or so
for example in in symmetric gaussian
elimination symmetric sparse gaussian
elimination
one of the algorithms that came out
fairly early in this history is
something called nested dissection a
term and an algorithm that was made up
by alan george in 1971
which is essentially a divide and
conquer way of
ordering the rows and columns of a
matrix to get a sparse to get a sparse
factorization
um
that was 1971 and over the years since
then people built better and better
separators better and better nested
dissection algorithms and also did
better and better
theory to show to show stronger and
stronger optimality results for it
and generally speaking over the last 50
years there have been a huge number of
graph algorithms that have contributed
to to uh practical numerical linear
algebra to solving solving linear
algebra on supercomputers
that's a different talk but the point i
want to make
here
is that nested dissection
took something over 20 years to go from
an algorithm with an implementation for
a special case
to
the algorithm that everyone used for
doing sparse gaussian elimination what
happened in those 50 years well
things became more generally applicable
during most of that time local greedy
algorithms that were not optimal
asymptotically
beat beat out nested dissection
what happened in those 20 years was that
n went to infinity well it got closer to
infinity in some metric than it was at
the beginning and what also happened was
that algorithms for
heuristic and approximate algorithms for
partitioning graphs got lots and lots
better and somehow in the early 1990s it
all came together and nobody
nobody's nobody used anything but nested
dissection anymore
so combinatorial laplacian algorithms uh
proven vija of course did his work
around 1990 or so spielman and tang
made their tremendous uh end times poly
log breakthrough in 2004. this is far
from being a complete list but then
um
giannis and gary and richard uh
in 2010 brought the brought the exponent
on log n down
and uh john at all
uh more recently gave an algorithm that
you can actually describe to somebody in
half an hour uh that's that's only a log
factor only a log fast factor slower
than that um
okay
it's been 20 years
so so why are combinatorial laplacian
algorithms not the algorithms that
everyone uses for solving laplacian
systems which lots and lots of people do
that's the challenge um
so
uh sivan raised a lot of questions
people in the audience raised a lot of
questions about the laplacian world
championships
i would like to spend
a few more minutes
extracting discussion on these sessions
set questions
i would like
let's see giannis would you be willing
to to spend a few minutes
um
uh let me let's let's do this first and
then and then and then if there's any
time left at the end i'll i'll talk and
other people will talk but um
as sivan said
i think well
i think this is enormously important at
this point in time i'm i i think
probably i count as one of sivan's full
professors who spend most of his career
doing high performance computing um um
but but i think it's time for this
community's
this this specific piece of what this
community has done
to
have
a significant real practical impact in
in
in in in
large-scale computing um
i think this is a great idea
why should you participate
what would make you more likely to take
part in this
what are the incentives we should do oh
and and we talked a little bit about
what are the right metrics um
so forth and so forth and test graphs
and so forth a lot of a lot of these
questions uh steven's already talked
about but uh
i i'm
one thing i'm interested in is is is the
incentive question
you're sitting there thinking boy this
is a great idea for somebody to do
what would what would make what would
make you think boy this would be a great
idea for me to get involved
so the question is how many are
how many here are doing it
how many we're just giving hands
how many groups are actually working on
different groups distinct groups are
actually working on implementing
various things
how many how is this
so
optimization that i like to complete
with those but it's not directly solving
laplacian systems but wait that would be
great because what we need is generators
for instances yeah and now we have
algorithms that take maxwell and solve
them by laplace linear systems but i
don't have natural max flow instances
if you have max flow instance you want
to solve then we should
it'd be great to somehow include those
then okay then they have to pipe through
an algorithm that turns max funds to
solving linear systems
we could perhaps say i don't if you guys
think we agree on one or two
because certainly the linear systems you
get at the end of those routines they're
very different
so the aggregate time would be
interesting
how much is good sorry just reflections
and how much is it just symmetric
diagonally dominance
um
our
focus is on
laplacian linear systems specifically i
mean of course they're you know their
reductions and so forth um
you have to you you have to draw a
circle around something i mean there's a
huge there's a huge
literature outside the theory community
on more and more general versions of of
uh of matrix problems but yeah
so how many groups
do we have
how many people maybe is what you get by
sure very well
yeah i have three undergrads who are
trying to figure out your code
yeah
so
i mean i think gary's good did actually
implement the whole thing and
i
am conjecturing that kerry uh strongly
interacted with practical
and uh
so
um
that's a little hard to arrange so
i would uh suggest
that
as part of what your infrastructure is
going to provide you provide essentially
a way of
posting interests and
abilities
and
there's a term for that i've actually
been working quite a bit in this area
innovation
marketplace
but just to give you uh sort of the idea
and the crudest version
um
you would
basically allow people to blog about you
know post about their
capabilities and their needs
so very primitive uh website would do
uh
you know one webpage page for
capabilities
and people would post
how they could be accessed
so i i mean i think people
misjudge
how difficult it is actually to produce
working code
and
i think
some people in the super computing
community
might be quite excited and willing to
provide those capabilities
but
john gilbert is and you guys are fairly
well connected with that community but
you need to get
them involved with this so right
so so to some to some extent
to some extent it's a coincidence that
we're pitching this to the theory
community first it's our it's our intent
to to
to give uh similar talks with with
different emphases in in other
communities but but one thing one point
one point that i think is important that
you're making john is that is that
matchmaking is going to be a real
important
job for the organizing committee i think
that's absolutely true and and one thing
you know it's going to be your
responsibility
that it implicitly
has to be
i mean it's really almost more important
than
posting the problems and posting the
results it's actually something that
you've never done before
but i think it's absolutely essential
so you have to
have a public essentially a marketplace
but a posting really bulletin board
where you post
people are able to post their
capabilities and without that
you're going to be down to i think i
count three groups competing
with all sorts of lost
opportunities
without that
certainly certainly making connections
between
people with different skills from
different communities is going to be one
of the most important parts of this
yeah
i mean i completely agree that he takes
people with different
uh kinds of expertise to to write a
solver that's good no i'm not just
saying that i'm saying that you have to
provide some format some some well
yes i agree the point i wanted to make
here
is that
it's possible for high performance
computing team existing high performance
computing teams to participate on their
own so here you know on the hill people
from from from
berkeley lab can probably form a team
and come up with something reasonable
my concern is that if they do this
without
strong theoreticians they will
you know they will reap the relatively
shallow ideas and that there are deeper
theoretical ideas that are too hard to
understand and to fall into the
implementations and then so and that we
will not extract the most benefit so i
think it's important for theoreticians
to participate in order to make sure
that the
the
implementation seat on a theory that's
as deep as necessary rather than is as
deep as somebody can digest
sibo sivan mentioned that that i mean of
course everyone knows that that gary and
janis and richard and gary's group going
back many years have been centrally
involved in a lot of these
implementations and i wanted to give
i wanted to ask giannis in particular if
he would be willing to spend
a few minutes
talking to us about his perspective on
on on on this whole question giannis
would you be willing to talk to us for a
lo for for a few minutes yes uh thank
you i'll even give you the microphone
how about that
well it's it's for the recording yes
so suppose i haven't prepared for this
but uh
what i can say is that
we worked on this
solver back in 2009 and i think the last
time i touched it
with that state
was
in 2011.
there have been no changes
in the whole 2010
and
so as you may know it's actually not
based on
the papers
with proofs
so it's based on a different idea that
gary
and
developed
which is based on using extra variables
called steiner variables
for actually constructing
preconditioners and what we did is to
actually work on the theoretical part
and understand these
preconditions a little more
and also combine them with multi-grid
type algorithms which gave this uh
this over so now uh this over uh
from what i hear a lot of people have
used it in their own at least and
it works well for many people but
i can certainly say that it's far from
uh from being optimized there's a lot of
room for improvements there both in the
combinatorial constructions and the
condition numbers so but also in in the
actual implementations
software engineering issues for example
uh either there is a metric spectrum
application
routine which is basically hand coded it
doesn't use any
existing libraries uh
in the past we have also worked on
trying to parallelize matrix vector
multiplication with gary and
guy
blelock and kanata
and
we actually obtained
four
time speed up in an eight core machine
but that required uh
an extensive uh
implementation of metadata
multiplication so perhaps we haven't you
know this is not yet
out the combination of the two and the
cnc and a much better uh metrics better
multiplication uh core is not there so
that's one improvement that perhaps we
can make
and
other improvements practical
improvements so certainly it would be
helpful to have people that understand
details about
coding
and
have them work on it
now
there is
possibly
something that can be done
in terms of the
condition numbers improvement of the
condition numbers
um
so
well
there is there is this work by
uh harold rayking
also he's here
he's there okay so he was tiny
so
he constructs this one
single trees
our congestion approximators you can
call them uh that are steiner trees uh
trees with externals and uh
the ideas in the sims disorder are based
on this type of ideas very close and
inspired by by his work actually
back then like in 2007 when i worked on
this room for my thesis uh
we weren't actually able to uh find them
fast
and there has been a lot of progress in
actually
designing combinatorial algorithms for
fine industries fast and the latest uh
contributions by research who gave uh
observe that you can actually find find
them in nearly linear time
now
based also harry's recent work and
i believe that it is uh we're very close
to actually
uh coming up with a theoretical uh
better theoretical understanding of
these standard preconditioners
uh and and what i mean by that is to
actually write a paper which claims an
upper bound uh for supports uh strict
upper bound like we have with the
subgraph pre-conditioners
and
this
particular theoretical direction we may
not look very
necessary at this point we have all
these other strong upper bounds but i
think if we actually improve it improve
the upper bounds for this type of
conditioning we will actually get
a much better cmz like code in terms of
the condition number to be honest yeah
i've heard you correctly yeah you gained
some theoretical insights from your from
your
uh implementation yes some questions
can you talk to me about what as a card
carrying theorist what value did you get
out of doing an implementation
what value did i get
as a
theoretician
the
uh the value that seems to uh
to be the most important part at least
now it looks like is that
there are there are people you know the
code has been published for a number of
years now and there are people in other
communities for example data mining
that slowly find their way to
to the code
years and
a lot of that is due to dan spades
who has posted the link to
my code and actually i see a lot of
traffic coming into my web page from his
uh page
and and
so i have actually helped people
apply
uh use the code and in the process you
know the code is used for certain
problems they have for example data
mining
i will actually be talking about that
tomorrow a little bit and sorry uh and
and so i'm actually in this way i can
also
help them uh correctly in some of the
problems they have so i think it
improves it
it improves the interaction that uh
happens between different communities
more applied and serious
so that's something we gain from for me
if i can reinterpret what you said yes
an excellent leading question okay
you're gay or you're gaining
citations from people using your code
that should they demonstrate impact
outside of your feet i will say i will
say no citations citation including
suggestions but i i think the most
valuable is actually collaborations i've
had people that i actually work with
people collaborate with people and try
to solve problems but you know here is a
question i have and actually that's
probably addresses some of this point is
that i would love to get involved here
but you know i am definitely i will not
even try to program anything because
this will be a disaster
how can i find person who will be
willing to like to talk to me and like
sort of the point is i say i know some
of you are you know how to code but you
are like half of the country away from
me and you know like
like this is for me this is the problem
i would love to collaborate with someone
who understands the system side of all
these applied algorithms and try to do
something more but
i can't find that that's such a person
how do you go about it it's like you
know
about it uh how do you find people
that's a good question so we have
one more question yeah yeah i guess
another way to phrase this is that we in
this room are excited about this
question is how do we get people who are
not in this room excited about it as
well because there's no point to build
this collaboration i'm actually more
worried about
so i'm glad to hear that you think
people were excited about this i was
more worried about this community
being enthusiastic than i was about a
more traditionally applied community i
think the challenge of course will be
that if a pure theoretician starts to
direct
you know someone in an implementation
train wreck dead ahead i mean there's
going to have to be give and take in
respect on both sides no it is not i'm
not saying that i would like i i need an
undergrad who will just code it out
that's not the point is that you're
saying no but you need someone who
understands that aspect exactly to have
a discussion and saying okay i have this
crazy idea and this person telling me
this will not work because of and that's
exactly what i need i don't have it and
without this i would to be hopeless for
you so you think the applied people will
be incentivized to
actually collaborate with us and learn
these algorithms i hope so that's
certainly our goal i might
i have a concern that they'll want to
take the existing algorithmic basis that
they have
just try it on these problems they'll
work on the 2d and 3d meshes they won't
work on the hard instances and you know
end of story
the hope is is that the the insight from
this community
will lead to
more highly robust and and uh you know
more broadly applicable implementations
that are you know more consistently
performant
and creating the the incentive on their
side to reach out and embrace and
frankly you know it's not these are not
simple papers to read i you know i don't
have to tell any of you that certainly
for an applied community and so and so i
think there will have to be a lot of
given
yeah i think the other part basically is
that
indeed
but on the other hand it's having a
concrete
package even though however rudimentary
does create other people you know
opportunity for other people to look
into it
because years ago i had
my experience of you know automatic
thesis we were writing for separator
theorem uh based on geometry
and
i think john global was first person to
coach me to at least uh write a very
small code in matanov
and very quickly was someone just
willingly poured into the thinking
machine scientific library the next
thing i saw is people take the matlab
code and just professionally according
to the scientific library
right uh no no
lender johnson and his students oh he
did it too
just direct reporting without my
interference and
and even the the first time i feel
really proud of is matlab
the network publisher uh
what you call calendar
well the calendar has
the petition we produce and which i
wouldn't even print it on it so i think
that somehow uh but otherwise if it's
just a paper absolutely people will say
hey nice to know you can do this and it
that's it it's very hard for somehow it
breaks through into the application
that's why i think it's terrific to have
each other complete end-to-end package
that the people can easily
plug into some other application like so
that's why i think the
in the sense that you can't just write
the code you have to have a good
interface you have to have you know all
those good designs so that people can
uh
simply simply somehow plug in then i
think other people may improve on you
afterwards right i think i
i think we should probably
probably we should wrap up the